sri lankans have been taking to the
streets for months demanding change the
economy's collapsed food prices go up
every day
it's hard to get your hands on medicine
and you have to line up for days for
fuel have a listen to what this
demonstrator has to say
we won't give up because what the
country need is a total
system change a lot of different i mean
we want to get rid of these corrupted
politicians
so that's what we are doing
well asset leader gotabaya rajapaksa who
fled the country after mass protests
over his handling of the economy is
replaced by prime minister vikrez
masinga on the right but he's seen as
his ally
protesters want both of them out
we don't believe in him this he's not
the
correct choice at this moment now
ranil is carrying over that ousted
corrupt president's legacy the people
of sri lanka has not been given what
they deserve which is peace
you know a
peace of mind
and
the basic necessities being met
there was high security around the
parliamentary complex as vikramasinga
took on his new role his office said he
wants to form a unity government to
manage the turmoil
the new president is a familiar face in
sri lanka
having served six times as prime
minister which in sri lanka is the
deputy to the president
he was sworn in and signed himself on
as the elected head of state
though in this case it was parliament
who elected him amidst the country's
turmoil
the crema singa's election had been
greeted by yet another surge of protests
in colombo from the same movement that
pushed out his predecessor as dw
correspondent manira chaudry explains
verdict for the past few days that we
saw when ranil took over as the prime
minister of the country and as the
acting president after president godeber
rajapaksa resigned people have been
frustrated they took over the pm's
office as well and protested saying that
they wanted ronald vikramazinga to step
down and now that he has won they are
not happy the krema singha has said he
will bring opposition lawmakers into his
cabinet but vowed a tough line after his
election against troublemakers
for those who seek to destroy
to threaten democracy
they must then be dealt with the law by
the law
for the others
i would like to bring everyone together
ranil vikramazinga is a lawyer turned
politician who won his first
parliamentary election in 1977.
he's considered a technocrat with deep
technical understanding of sri lanka's
economic woes
he says negotiations on an international
monetary fund bailout are near a deal
but his toughest task may be distancing
himself from his ties to the previous
government
and convincing those who already want
him out
that he should stay
let's analyze this with lawyer activist
and former commissioner of the human
rights commission of sri lanka
great to have you here what's going to
happen next with the turmoil in your
country
uh well it's hard to predict because mr
ronald mikrimasingha was sworn as
president today
and
the fact is he did not win his seat uh
to parliament in the general elections
in 2020 when he was appointed as prime
minister by the previous president mr
gotham raj baxter there was a lot of
opposition uh and an uproar public
uproar uh when he um was nominated uh to
contest for the position of parliament
which he won with the votes of the
previous president's party all of which
show that he does not have public trust
or public legitimacy and also that he is
in a way
a proxy for the raj boxers because they
nominated him and their party elected
him which means he's also going to be
protecting them and this might just turn
out to be more of the same
no matter the the lack of legitimacy or
his links
does he have the ability to to fix the
nation's problems despite that
well uh
the point is that we um well one would
uh hope he does but also the issue is
that we must not look to him only as an
individual and there are many who are
saying that the other candidates for
instance would not have been able to and
uh i think that one of the problems that
sri lanka has always had is focusing on
individuals and making them saviors
instead of focusing on our institutions
and our processes and strengthening them
whoever is in that position they do need
to follow certain steps they need to
listen to the experts and they need to
keep the national interest at heart so
the best option that we see going
forward towards economic recovery in
order to have stability is to call for
general elections as soon as practically
possible
isn't that going to stretch things out
even further i mean what happens in the
meantime while sri lanka which is
bankrupt waits for its bailout from the
international monetary fund which is
going to take months
well the international monetary fund has
i just saw they've announced today that
they plan to uh complete the
negotiations as soon as possible
and uh also uh elections um there's a
myth also created about the fact that we
can't afford elections but once again
there can also be assistance that we can
obtain to hold it and while we wait for
elections to be held or preparations are
being made uh mr vikramazinga will still
be president which means he should
continue with the business of governing
in the national interest
and beca what happens though in the
meantime with uh the the protests i i'm
sure a lot of those demonstrators aren't
going to give up
yes and yeah yesterday and again today
uh many of them uh have said that they
will not give up because they do not
find him legitimate and that they will
continue so that we have to see how that
uh progresses uh particularly the
students who have been at the forefront
of the protests have said that they will
not give up until he
resigns in that sense to have a
president particularly during such a
time of turmoil when the public is
suffering a president who does not seem
to also have empathy and who does not
have public trust is cause for great
concern so what we hope as i said before
is that we can go for general elections
and uh we can also have a parliament
that is different and not in the
clutches of the raj boxes that will
enable us to move towards economic
recovery and stability okay we'll be
closely watching this i'm sure you will
be two former commissioner of the human
rights commission of sri lanka ambika
satikunan thank you
there's another problem we haven't
talked about yet and that is that sri
lanka also needs tourism it's a huge
money spinner it once pumped billions of
dollars into the economy in 2018 around
5 of gross domestic product but in 2019
a terror attack devastated the sector
then the pandemic shut down everything
and who wants to visit a country
suffering from what's now become a
humanitarian crisis when the people
can't even afford to feed themselves
some blame sri lanka's close ties with
china for its economic collapse
beijing extended 12 billion dollars in
loans to the government between 2000 and
2020 infrastructure projects like the
one behind me
the multi-billion dollar port in
hambantota hometown of recently fled
president gotabaya rajapaksa was a
flagship project in china's belton road
initiative when it opened in 2010.
seven years later the port was ceded to
chinese control after sri lanka realized
it could no longer pay off the loans a
case study in debt trap diplomacy
beijing is sri lanka's single biggest
creditor accounting for 10 of the
country's foreign debt
the pandemic soaring energy costs and
global food shortages brought about by
the ukraine war have left states like
pakistan philippines and laos struggling
to pay their belt and road obligations
china says it will help sri lanka but
it's vague on the details
china's ready to work with countries and
financial institutions to keep playing a
positive role in helping sri lanka
overcome its difficulties and ease its
debt burden
with china's own economy under pressure
state banks are more eager than ever to
collect on belton road debt
clifford conan reported from china for
years and has closely watched the
rollout of this new silk road project
no one's forced sri lanka to sign up to
anything but
why if the international monetary fund
offers rates of between one and three
percent would you sign up to a lending
rate of three to six percent
well one of the great things about the
belt and road project for a lot of
countries is the fact that these loans
come with pretty much no strings
attached uh china doesn't do the same
levels of due diligence that the imf
does so for example when the imf lends
money you have to show that it's
sustainable that you will be able to pay
it back and you usually have to reform
yourself as well that's right you have
to do these sort of things you have to
be transparent in how you do the
dealings china doesn't really care about
that and um that's why i mean even in
this particular deal that the hambantota
port is is in rajapaksa their in their
hometown uh shows that uh you know
there's clearly special in their own
interests are being represented here and
the imf might have had a problem with
that for example so you can sort of see
that there's a lot of these different
elements at work but then it's a a
win-win isn't it for for china or
lose-lose for sri lanka by by the sounds
of it um what's china going to do about
this though because
it could all backfire if if they don't
get their money back
that's right well as we saw in the
report china's being quite vague about
it they say they're going to be
supportive um but there aren't really
any precedence for them in this i mean
this is the most severe test that the
belt and road initiative has faced in in
the in the nine years since it was
started um so it remains we'll have to
see if they're going to um if they're
going to really push people
if they're going to start seizing assets
which is what happened in in in sri
lanka before with the port
and that would be very serious would
also be a big boost for china's regional
um strategy of of becoming more
prominent and of increasing its muscle
in the region
talking about the region what about
india one of china's rivals uh sri
lanka's closest neighbor and a big
investor as well yeah i mean there's a
big power play going on between india
and china right now we've seen this in
many in many different areas uh they're
professing closeness at the moment
because they're part of the brics
grouping with brazil and russia that
they're all sort of um that they're
showing this sort of new closeness but
at the back of it there's still a lot of
regional issues between the two um india
has just overtaken china as the most
populous nation in in the world um or is
about to this year um so there's a lot
of competitive competition between the
two um india is not really involved in
the in the belton road uh initiative and
it's um it's basically wants to push its
own interests so i think that um we're
going to see they've they've given a lot
of money to sri lanka a lot of support
um i think we're going to see more of
that and um china is really going to
have to step up if it wants to
to win with this uh you know this cap to
capture sri lanka's hearts and minds
it's going to have to step up its
activities clifford kunin thank you very
much